the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
and to try something out a little real I
took a detector that you all have as
well my cell phone and this morning I
went down with EHS to one of the very
radioactive cobalt-60 sources a 10 mil
aqui resource if you note the source
that we were playing around here was as
one micro Curie so this was a 10,000
times stronger source and was actually
able to show the difference between a
background count of my phone you
shouldn't see much going on except for
that one malfunctioning pixel because
not much is going on and when I put the
phone over the source itself things look
a little different you guys see all that
digital noise or snow in the video every
one of those white flashes that you see
is a gamma interaction with the
semiconductor in the cell phone camera
with one or more pixels in your CCD or
charge-coupled device or your CMOS
detector whichever one it happens to be
so I thought this was pretty cool you
can actually use your cell phone as a
radiation detector and we're gonna
understand why and what sort of
radiation it could detect by virtue of
its size and its composition today
anyone ever try this before you have
probably more intense than this if you
were making neutrons right now awesome
okay cool so let's just first figure out
well where is this radiation coming from
this is the link between the first part
of the course and what we're gonna be
doing over the next month as we've seen
from the decay diagrams and I think I've
harped on potassium-40 as an example for
a reason it can undergo electron capture
or positron release and if it undergoes
electron capture by this likely route it
gives off a one point four six one MeV
gamma ray as the only possible
transition here it also undergoes beta
decay which you don't want to forget
about if you're calculating the activity
of potassium-40 but today we're gonna be
focusing on what does this gamma ray
actually do when it encounters matter or
what are they uh possible things that
can happen I'm going to introduce them
conceptually today and we're gonna go
through the math of the cross sections
and the energetics more tomorrow so I'm
doing a context first theory second kind
of approach there's three main things
that gamma rays will do in matter
depending on their energy and the actual
matter itself there's one called the
photoelectric effect where a gamma ray
simply ejects an electron from the
nucleus so let's say we've got our
potassium-40 atom have a bunch of
electron shells I'm not going to draw
all the electrons but I'll draw a few
inner and outer ones here one of the
things that the gamma ray can do is just
eject that electron havecome firing out
and the energy balance for that isn't
that hard because this gamma has some
energy e gamma this electron had some
binding energy E binding and the kinetic
energy let's call it T of the electron
is simply the gamma ray n minus the
binding energy back out it's just
however much energy it takes to remove
that electron that's what it takes and
so you end up with if we go back to our
banana spectrum what we call a photo
peak or a photoelectric emission peak
right here if you trace down this
it's awfully close to 1469 ke V or 1.46
what was it one point four six one MeV
it won't be exactly at that energy
because it does take a little bit of
energy to remove that electron anyone
have a guess on what order of magnitude
that might be
yeah KETV all the way down to Evy so
this photo peak will typically be
extremely close but not exactly equal to
the energy of the gamma ray coming out
for most detectors that don't have that
good resolution you can pretty much
assume they'll be in the same channel or
the same energy bin because your
detector will have some sort of
resolution it may have a thousand 24 or
2048 channels that span the full energy
range and you might not be able to tell
the difference between 14 60 MeV or
41.46 MeV and that - a few easy
potassium in particular has quite a
small work function then we'll get into
why that is in a second the next thing
it can do is what's called Compton
scattering in the general case which is
means that there's an electron here a
gamma ray comes in with a gamma and then
it bounces off with some energy E prime
gamma and then the electron goes off
with some other kinetic energy then the
last one is what's called pair
production just like in the QED equation
if you have anything related to
positrons you have to first create them
so pair production doesn't happen below
about 1.0 to 2 MeV and it happens with
increasing probability as the energy of
the photon goes up kind of like in
radioactive decay there's a lot of
parallels here is you can make a photo
you can make an electron-positron pair
at 1.0 to 2 MeV is just not very likely
and it's an what we're gonna find out
tomorrow is why the most likely photon
effect is shown in these different
regions anyone have any idea why do you
think the photoelectric effect would be
most likely at low energies and high Z
you just had to give an intuitive guess
yeah Luke
that's right so that that explains the
low-energy idea so that it doesn't take
very much in fact does anyone know what
the minimum energy you need to make the
photoelectric effect happen well what is
what's what's a typical order of
magnitude for binding energy of the
lowest or the the outermost electron
shell or the lowest bound electron
mm-hmm yeah that's called the work
function anyone know an order of
magnitude guess what it is it's in the
single Eevee range in some cases it can
even be slightly lower and that that
were talking about visible light so like
green light even yellow light can eject
electrons via the photoelectric effect
and then the reason that goes more
likely with higher and higher Z we'll
get into that when we look at the
different cross-sections of interaction
payer production is much more likely at
higher energies because at higher energy
you're more likely to create a positron
and in addition pair production happens
when a photon interacts with either the
electron cloud or the nucleus there and
that gets more and more likely let's say
the denser the electron cloud is or the
higher charge there is on the nucleus so
first the simplest one the photoelectric
effect this is actually what Einstein
won the Nobel Prize for not equals MC
squared which has been the bane of our
all existence for the last month that's
not what he got the Nobel Prize for it
was demonstration of the photoelectric
effect where if you start firing photons
of an energy time Planck's constant
times its frequency and then the next
page I'll give you a quick photon math
primer in case you don't know what those
quantities are there will be no
photoelectric emission until you hit
that work function yeah like like Julia
was saying that lowest bound electron
energy and then the emission will simply
go up and so this was demonstrated by
applying a voltage to two different
plates two different metal plates and
then sending in light via this window
and seeing when the current actually
became nonzero so the way you detect
photoelectric emission
is if you've got electrons boiling off
of one surface to the other that's the
movement of charge and that's a current
and so you can measure a current with an
ammeter that's it actually is that
simple but very elegant experiment back
to the 1910s or 1920s and as a quick
primer on photon quantity so you know
what all of these different symbols mean
the photon energy we give as Planck's
constant times its frequency and I'll
give you Planck's constant right here
for reference I do recommend that you
guys try checking out all the units to
make sure that they work out because if
you ever forget is that you know H times
nu or is it HC over lambda you can
always check the units of your
expression to make sure they come out to
an energy which an SI units is what
joules and then how about in these sorts
of things the most reduced SI units is
what evey is another unit of energy
similar to the Joule like one point six
times ten to the minus 19 joules but
what about in meters kilograms seconds
other SI units yep kilogram meter
squared per second squared
indeed third meter squared per second
squared yeah so just make sure that just
make sure you remember that because if
you're just looking for Jewel's you
don't remember what a Joule is it's
gonna make unit balance kind of hard and
also we can describe the momentum or P
of the photon as Planck's constant over
lambda its wavelength this is going to
get real important when I ask you guys
to do a derivation much like the Q
equation one that we were doing before
but instead of me just doing it at the
board and you copying it down I want you
guys to try working through it and it's
going to be another energy and momentum
conservation thing just like before and
this way you'll know what the energy is
and you'll know what the momentum is so
now on to this work function what is it
actually there's a great paper by
Michelson I did not look up whether this
is the Michelson of Michelson
interferometry but I wouldn't be
surprised I'm gonna check into that but
I did dig out this paper that
actually shows the different patterns in
the work functions of different elements
so what do you guys notice in terms of
patterns here first of all which
elements are all the way to the left or
have the lowest work function the what
the group one metals like sodium lithium
potassium why do you think that is
they've got 1 electron in their
outermost shell so looks like my
potassium picture is not quite accurate
I'm gonna draw another shell and put 1
lone electron in that for accuracy and
so that electron is extremely unbound
that's the same reason that these
elements are so chemically reactive they
want to ditch that electron to have a
filled outer shell so you may also
expect the work function of noble gases
to be extremely high I don't know if any
are plotted here but you do see the next
row over like barium strontium calcium
magnesium has a slightly higher work
function and as you move this way
through the periodic table to the left
until you hit the transition metal
craziness it follows a pretty regular
pattern and so you can have a good guess
of what the work function of something
will be depending on at Z and depending
on which wrote what is it which column
it's in in the periodic table now can
anyone tell me why do you think that
work functions tend to increase with
decreasing Z yeah indeed yep exactly for
smaller Z that first you know that first
or second shell is a hell of a lot
closer to the nucleus even though it has
a lower total charge in the nucleus it's
much more tightly bound being much
closer
so like the outermost electron and
cesium is quite far away and does not
feel as much Coulomb attraction yeah
good point
so now into Compton scattering I'd say
though the most difficult conceptually
to understand the energetics but the
kinematics or what actually physically
happens should look strikingly similar
to what we've spent the last month on
instead of two particles colliding
it's a photon colliding with an electron
then e1 remember what we read in that
first day of class with the Chadwick
paper when he said hey maybe this
quantum of energy is done in a process
analogous to Compton scattering well
this is Compton scattering his analogous
process was maybe an electron hits a
proton and something happens which is
not actually what happens and in this
case you have a
a photon with energy H nu and momentum H
nu / C striking an electron with rest
mass M of electron C squared or 0.5 1 1
MeV and afterwards the photon leaves at
some angle theta and the electron leaves
at some angle fee so we are I'm going to
show you guys some of the Compton
scattering energetics relations like
what is the wavelength shift which means
that if this photon comes in with a
certain wavelength lambda and it gives
some of its energy to the electron it
comes out at a different wavelength it's
going to be lower or higher wavelength
do you think
I heard a bit of both so who says lower
so lower wavelength let's go back to the
photon formula with a lower wavelength
result in a lower or a higher photon
energy okay so in a Compton scatter you
start off with an electron kind of at
rest they're definitely not actually at
rest but compared to the energy of the
photon there are at rest enough and then
you give some of that energy to the
electron that Energy's got to go down
and because these two quantities here
are constants the wavelength has got to
increase and hopefully this makes
intuitive sense the photon does what we
call a red shift it shifts closer to the
red end of the visible spectrum than the
blue end and as you guys know the
high-energy light in the visible
spectrum hits towards the ultraviolet
that's what tans you or gives you skin
cancer red light or infrared light
doesn't do much of anything at all and
so this is that on the extreme scale
where when we say redshift we don't
necessarily mean the photon is visible
but we do mean that it's shifting to a
lower a lower energy or a higher
wavelength and so this wavelength shift
is always going to be well is it going
to be positive or negative
is what so you say the wavelength shift
is gonna be positive which would mean an
increase in wavelength there you go
yep cuz it's got to be it's got to lose
energy so I'm not going to go through
the derivation of these because I want
you guys to go through the derivation
but we're going to do it in the exact
same way and I'll help kind of kick you
off where in this case what are the
three quantities we can conserve and
like every physics everywhere mass
energy and momentum the trick here is
what is the mass of the photon massless
so we've got energy and momentum and
we've got let's say some wavelength
shift to determine which is some change
in energy and we've got two angles to
deal with
that's three unknowns we need three
equations so we know that our initial
energy coming in is going to be H nu
plus approximately zero becomes H nu bar
and the kinetic energy of the electron
so that's our energy conservation
relation and then what do we do about
the momenta what do we do last time
exactly split it up into X&Y momentum so
the X momentum of the photon so I'll
just label this as energy put the X
momentum of the photon is H nu over C
and there was no X momentum of the
electron to begin with so then we're
going to say this has outgoing momentum
H nu prime over C times cosine theta
plus whatever the electron momentum is
let's say M electron V or root 2m
electron t electron cosine fee and then
how about the Y momentum what's the Y
momentum of the system at the beginning
yep nothing for the Photon nothing for
the electron and at the end we've got H
nu over C sine theta minus because it's
in the negative y direction momentum of
the electron sine fee I'm gonna stop my
part of the derivation there cuz I don't
want to steal away your whole homework
problem but you're going to start it out
exactly in the same way as we were doing
kinematics of two particle collisions
because what is a particle about a wave
they're all the same thing it's modern
physics and then here's an interesting
bit here this maximum wavelength shift
if you want to figure out what is the
well let's say what is what's called we
call it the Compton wavelength so if you
were to decide what is the maximum
wavelength shift where would that be
at what angle
hmm
did you have a question or did you say
what was it what was the question oh
okay sure is what is that angle PI over
2 because at that point cosine cosine of
PI over 2 equals 0 yep and so then you
get this interesting result no matter
what the incoming energy of the photon
is you get this zero point 2 3 8 MeV
shift and that's actually gonna help
explain to jump back to our banana
spectrum what the distance is between
our photo peak which is our
photoelectric peak which is pretty close
to the energy of the photon and this
part right here which we call the
Compton edge which would mean the
maximum scattered energy of that photon
in this case or no I'm sorry that would
be the maximum energy imparted to the
electron almost misspoke there and no
matter what this energy the photon is
that distance right there that's the
Compton wavelength interesting quirk of
physics huh because in the end all that
matters is if the angle is all the same
everything else cancels out and you just
get a bunch of constants I jump back to
there so now we'll take another look at
our detector spectrum and start
identifying some of these Peaks if you
notice this point 2 3 8 MeV looks just
like what it does on the graph so this
is the kind of cool thing like you guys
threw some bananas in a detector last
week we got a spectrum yesterday morning
and how well timed it was we're actually
going to start explaining it today
there's a whole lot more going on in
this banana spectrum part of what we'll
be explaining tomorrow is why do you get
this kind of bowl shape this Compton
Bowl and it turns out that there's a is
a different probability of scattering at
every different angle or what we call a
differential cross-section a D theta
over D Omega because the probability of
that photon scattering off in any
direction is not equal but if you know
what direction the photons scatter is
often
you know what energy it has or you know
what sort of energy it gives to the
electron because that's a one-to-one
relation and that's why you end up with
this very smooth almost cosine ish
looking kind of curve and you guys will
actually get to derive that yourselves
so then on to the wavelength and energy
shift by looking at the electron recoil
energy and this wavelength shift from
that you can actually get some sort of
an energy shift you can arrive at what
is the recoil energy of that electron
and so here's one of the topics that's
usually hard for folks to understand but
I want to stress it right now when you
send gamma rays into a detector draw an
imaginary detector in fact let's draw
the real one that we used in our banana
counting experiment so we had these
copper walls we had our bag of bananas
and we had our high purity germanium
detector let's say we had a good shield
on top and then a good shield on the
bottom that right there is our active
detector and this banana is sending off
gamma rays into that detector the way a
detector works is not by counting the
energy of the gamma ray directly it
can't actually do that in this germanium
detector you've got a huge voltage
applied across it think what Mike Ames
actually said was the one we used was
about 2,000 volts what happens here is
let's say I'll actually need three
colors for this let's say a gamma ray
comes in that's our gamma ray and
interacts in the detector that gamma ray
will redshift let me get a redder color
because that'll be like physically
accurate that gamma ray is going to hit
an electron go off at a different angle
and redshift or get lower in wavelength
meanwhile that electron that it hit
actually goes flying off and in the
other direction we're gonna call it a
hole a defect missing one electron of
some sort in this semiconductor normally
if there was no voltage applied here
these two would just find each other and
annihilate and you would have nothing so
much to count but by applying a gigantic
voltage let's say this voltage was
really plus and this voltage was really
minus this electron keeps on moving and
this hole keeps on moving to the
electrodes instead of recombining in the
detector they're actually then sent
through where they're counted in some
sort of ammeter or some sort of energy
pulse counter and what we're actually
measuring is the recoil spectrum of the
electrons that the photons make you're
not directly measuring photon energy
you're measuring the electron effects
part of that is because chances are
photons just go through everything this
is why I wasn't so worried this morning
standing with my face over a 10 military
cobalt source because while I was
getting billions of gammas per second
flying through my brain most of those
billions just flew out the other side
it's literally in one ear out the other
and so most of these gammas if they
interact at all will escape again the
electrons however because they're
charged and very low mass have a very
low range in the detector so chances are
the electrons that are made are gonna
stay there unless you happen to make one
like right here at that surface a few
atoms and it escapes that almost never
happens so forget that
and this was last year a huge source of
confusion to say why are we seeing some
of the other peaks that I'll be
explaining in like five or ten minutes
or why aren't we seeing 0.23 8 MeV peak
because what you're seeing here is a
photon losing that it's energy minus
0.23 8 MeV in its maximum energy
transfer which is given to that electron
then what actually happens next is this
electron slams into a bunch of other
ones and that slams into a bunch of
other ones until all the energy is lost
in the detector and all of those
electrons get sucked into the electrode
by this very high voltage and then the
way you count the energy of an
interaction is by how many electrons you
get in a certain little amount of time
and so that's why for example for the
photo peak that's this kind of simplest
reaction a gamma goes in a really high
electron comes out it smashes into tons
of other electrons imparting all of its
kinetic energy in the detector which is
all summed up in a nanosecond or however
long we collect for and then we say that
we saw an energy blip containing about
14 60 ke v of energy it all came from
that first gamma and then it was all
given to that first photo peak electron
which then slammed into a whole bunch of
others and they slammed into a bunch of
others there's this what's called this
ionization cascade where a whole bunch
of electrons make a whole bunch more
until all of them have too little energy
to ionize anything else and then they're
just collected so that's what we mean by
a pulse in a detector it's not exactly
an intuitive concept because it's not
like the gamma goes in and we just count
its energy there's more things that
physically happen in here but it's
important for you guys to know
especially when we start to look at pair
production you guys remember some of
this stuff from the positron
annihilation spectroscopy well the way
we actually know that positron
annihilation spectroscopy or pas works
is by measuring photons or their
eventual
electron recoils that can only be
possible from this process so as a quick
review let's say you had a positron
source like sodium 22 which naturally
undergoes radioactive decay and forms a
positron along with a gamma ray from a
very short isomeric transition or I T
then that positron bounces around in the
material until it reaches an electron
and once it hits that electron because
the positron let's say the rest mass of
the positron is the same as the rest
mass of the electron which is 0.5 1 1
MeV once the two of these combine they
annihilate producing 2 5 1 1 ke V or 0.5
1 1 MeV photons and it's those photons
at this exact energy all the time that
really give it away because there's not
many other processes that produce a huge
amount of exactly that Photon
now that we've talked a little bit about
momentum and energy conservation does
anybody know why you get what's called a
blue shift or a red shift in positron
annihilation spectroscopy I'll give you
a hint it goes down to conserving the
same things that we're doing all the
time yeah Kristin
your clothes I mean technically your
clothes if you treat electrons as waves
would you totally can the electrons
themselves do have a nonzero momentum as
they're flying about in the atom or
around the nucleus and when a electron
collides with a positron if that
electron already has some momentum
associated with it then the cell system
of mass was not at rest it's moving at
some small speed so this little minus
Delta energy in plus Delta energy
accounts for the initial momentum of the
electron which means not only can you
tell like from the lifetime how many
electron looking defects there are but
you can probe electron momentum by
looking at the slight energy changes as
positrons collide with electrons it's a
really cool and powerful technique that
uses only 2201 concepts to probe matter
at its deepest level so what's happening
on the atomic scale is let's say a
photon made a positron and the positron
bounces about what's called thermal ices
or just slows down via collisions via
other types of collisions that will go
in too soon and then gets trapped in a
defect which is a relatively electron
poor place but it doesn't matter no
electrons like you know in every space
everywhere there's a probability that
there's an electron in it in a defect
not containing an atom that probability
is lower but not zero and so by figuring
out how long they last
and when those 511 ke V gammas are
emitted you can tell let's say what size
defect that was but now let's talk about
what happens to these 511 ke V gammas
what evidence do we have that positron
or pair production actually exists so
before I reveal the labels can anyone
tell me what on this graph suggests that
positrons are happening and there's
actually two things what do you think
yeah that's right that's exactly right
there's a peak at 5:11 ke V that they
trace that up yeah I went went over yeah
right there five-eleven ke V is it
exactly 5 11 kV what do you guys think
so forget the fact that it came from a
positron let's say a 5-11 ke V gamma
came in somewhere
how would it then release electrons to
be counted it then undergoes
photoelectric emission so the actual
energy of this would be 511 ke V minus
the work function of the material this
is one of those tricky questions that
you might not even see it on the
spectrum but I want you to physically
understand what happens here it's not
like 511 ke V positron photons magically
get counted at 511 kV they then have to
eject an electron somehow and for those
electrons to be counted they have to
interact in exactly the same way as all
the other electrons there's no
difference what else oh yeah good
question
[Music]
that was my next question to you so
let's think about this a little bit
we'll start off with gammas being
emitted in all directions from our bag
of banana ashes now the question is
where do these 511 ke V photons come
from
if the gamma ray interacts with the
detector by any mechanism including pair
production what are the possible things
that could happen there's three
different scenarios let's pick a 511 ke
V color well first of all it might just
undergo a pair production and it'll
release to 511 ke V gammas
let's see those are there are five 11 kV
gammas and because their gammas and they
interact with almost nothing they can
get out so you might end up your energy
that you detect in the detector might be
the energy of your gamma ray -2 times
511 MeV this is what we refer to as
double escape close the quotes like that
so if this gamma ray right here came in
at 14 60 ke V and the double escape peak
if it undergoes pair production in the
detector and both of those 5 11s escape
because a lot of them do where would you
expect there to be a double escape peak
on this spectrum
yeah let's say you add that - so we're
at 14 60 minus 1.0 - - that comes out to
about 450 ke V for 50 K easy right here
not much going on is there you're not
gonna see it in every detector
especially the larger the detector is
the less likely both of those photons
are going to escape so this is where the
concept of detector size can tell you
whether or not you're going to see every
peak that's physically happening so in
this case the germanium detector is
pretty big it's pretty expensive so
chances are a lot of those 511 K V's
even though they're are produced in
pairs one of them didn't quite get out
yeah Luke
that's right dad yeah that's right why
don't we write that down in steps for
let's call this pair production in the
detector so step one would be gamma
emission step 2 would be electron
positron creation step 3 would be
annihilation no lotion in the detector
and then step 4 would be somewhere
between zero to two photons escape so we
have actually three scenarios that could
happen here for pair production inside
the detector one of them we just
described where a pair production
happens you get anihilation in a very
short time frame like tens of Pico
seconds or hundreds of Pico seconds both
the gammas get out that would have
produced a 460k EVP which it might be
there but I can't tell if that's a P
curve if that's noise so we don't really
know and chances are the reason that
didn't happen is because the detector
was big so an X next possibility what if
one of those photons gets out and one of
them doesn't it then interacts via
compton scattering or photoelectric
effect or any of the possible mechanisms
then you'll end up with an energy
counted equal to energy of the gamma
minus only one of those things getting
out and we call that single escape at
what energy would that single escape
peak be
oh it would be that pink people be at
the energy of the gamma 1460 -5 11 kV so
roughly 900 kV or so there we go
there it is that's the second bit of
evidence that there is pear production
going on not only do you have a peak at
5:11 kv which we have not explained yet
but you also have the single escape peak
which is the energy of your gamma minus
1 escape from a 5-11 ke V photon photon
yeah yes I mean it what I escaped I mean
it escapes the detector and is no longer
counted so it might go and dropped
somewhere else but your detector doesn't
know it so what's the third scenario
that could happen what if zero of these
photons escape what energy will you
count exactly so all that's going to
happen is it's going to look like the
photoelectric effect in reality you'll
have slightly slightly lower energy
because you have three work functions to
subtract off from the three photons
doing stuff but I would count that as
correct it's gonna look just like the
photoelectric effect first you get that
energy minus one point o2 2 MeV and then
both of those 511 ke V photons interact
in the detector by probably
photoelectric emission and you just get
another count at this channel right here
now the last question I want to ask you
guys where did this peak come from under
what circumstance would the detector
just count 511 ke V
I'll give you a hint there's a reason I
drew gammas going off in every direction
yep so most of the gamers don't hit the
detector but let's say you had a gamma
that went into anything else like the
copper shielding and it underwent pair
production and one of those gammas made
it to the detector I'm sorry one of
those photons made it to the detector
that's actually where these things are
coming from because most of those gammas
are not heading towards the detector
this is a very small solid angle but
surrounding the rest of the detector is
this really dense copper and these
high-energy gammas in this relatively
high Z material undergoes a lot of pair
production so it's firing out 511 ke V
photons in all directions and some of
those enter the detector when nothing
else enters the detector and that's why
you get this 511 ke V peak right here so
we haven't explained every peak on this
graph does anybody have any ideas where
what's that about or that or those
yeah could be cosmic rays that's
probably what's contributing to a lot of
the noise here as well as thermal noise
in the detector but what else haven't we
accounted for now to bring this a little
more into reality we ran an experiment
where we burned bananas we didn't put a
potassium-40 certified source in we put
bananas in what else could be going on
other isotopes that's right but you can
identify them quite easily one by
checking to see where you expect the
photo peak so just from the decay
diagram you'll expect to see some
interactions or photoelectric effect
interactions at these transition levels
luckily you know they're not due to
potassium because potassium Zone Li got
one of them in addition you should see
some very similar features so if you
have a photo peak here you would expect
to see another compton edge 0.23 8 MeV
away and it's kind of hard to tell if
it's going on because that's a rather
weak photo peak and you would expect
then for the high-energy gammas to see
another single escape peak maybe right
there and add to the 511 ke V peak
because those are all the same so when
you take the spectrum of a real thing
and you have two deconvolution stitch
ooh --nt interactions it's important to
know what all these possible
interactions are so that you can take
them apart and say start off with a
photo peak which should tell you what
elements are there and then you can
subtract off the expected amount of
compton scattering the expected amount
of single escape peak and then see
what's left over
what other isotopes may there be that
you haven't accounted for yet so the
last thing I want us to try as a mental
exercise
is to draw to spectra let's say this
will be energy versus intensity and for
this I want you to imagine that you're
at first your detector is very small and
then I want you to imagine that your
detector is very large and I'm gonna
keep this visible so you can have this
as a mental model if we had just one
isotope potassium-40
what do you think the spectra would look
like for an extremely small detector and
for an extremely large detector so where
do we start
that's right
and it will there be any difference
between the two probably not so a small
detector maybe a large detectors going
to have I don't know a larger intensity
but for the same type of detector you're
gonna have pretty much the same thing
what's next
compton edge so there's going to be some
energy that compton scattering is going
to start out and then it's going to
proceed up the slee is there gonna be
any real effect of the detector size
probably not because as soon as you
release that compton electron that
electron slams into all the other ones
and nanometers or microns of material
and all the energy is collected what's
the real difference going to be
that's right so though a 5-11 peak and
the other associated ones so for a
really really small detector we have the
possibility for a double escape peak a
single escape peak and just more photo
peak what's the most likely scenario
double escape so if we go down here
let's say if this difference is 1.0 to 2
MeV you would expect a larger double
escape peak and what would you expect
your single escape peak to be
significantly smaller so let's say this
difference right here is 5 11 kV how
about for a large detector quite the
opposite
you might expect a tiny or even
non-existent
double escape peak maybe a large or
single escape peak but most of the time
you're just going to add on to your
photo peak depending on the resolution
of the detector because in this case for
a small detector if you have an
interaction inside that volume chances
are most of those 5 11s get out for a
large detector chances are most of them
stay in and undergo their own Compton
scattering or photo peak reactions so
let's say that all these detectors will
also have a 511 ke V we'll just mark
that off let's just give them the same
height what else are we missing if this
is an ideal scenario with no noise
well what are those five what can those
five eleven ke V photons do can they
make peer production of their own no
they're not high enough energy in fact
they're half the required energy can
they undergo photoelectric effect sure
that's probably where we're getting
those five Elevens can they undergo
Compton scattering why not there's no
minimum energy to scatter so what you're
going to end up with then is 238 kV away
you should have another little confident
at a distance of 238 KETV away from the
511 kV
now in reality you probably won't see it
cuz you're gonna have other x-rays
you'll have bremsstrahlung which we'll
talk about tomorrow which is that
breaking radiation you'll have
background radiation and it might be
hard to see but technically it should be
there because any photon of any energy
is going to have that same sort of
Compton edge shape the shape changes
just a little bit depending on the
energy of the photon but you're always
gonna have an edge you're always gonna
have some sort of a bowl just how big
the edge is compared to the bowl well
we'll get to that tomorrow so it's a
little after 505 of I think this is a
good place to stop because it's the full
conceptual explanation of the ways that
photons can interact with matter so I
want to ask you guys if you have any
questions based on what we've done today
yep yep
that's right so the electron and the
positron annihilate turning their mass
into energy since the rest mass of each
of those is 5 11 kV the photons come off
at 511 KB yep good question the positron
is not a whole so like here where we
were talking about an electron hole pair
a hole would be lets say an atom with a
missing electron a positron is a
particle itself of antimatter that has
the same mass but the opposite charge as
the electron and so every particle has
got its antimatter component like there
are antiprotons and antineutrons that if
they find their regular matter selves do
annihilate yep so a small detector would
see double escape because at first let's
say a gamma ray interacts and undergoes
pair production and so it's going to
let's say create an electron-positron
pair and it's going to give them a whole
lot of extra energy so they're gonna
knock around and ionize things and
that's going to count up to the made-out
energy at a gamma minus 1 MeV then when
they annihilate if it's a small detector
chances are those gammas just get out
we're gonna be going over why soon when
we get into mass attenuation
coefficients or cross sections or
interaction probabilities but as the
energy of a gamma goes up that's
interaction probability goes way down
and this is a fairly high energy photon
compared to like the easier ke V x-rays
that you tend to see so chances are
these these photons get made from
annihilation but they don't stay in the
detector then the bigger the detector is
the more mass there is in the way and
more the more likely they get counted
but all of this happens well at the
speed of light leads the photon part and
so it's so fast that the detector picks
it up as that sum of all the different
processes of energy in one time interval
this is like I said this is the harder
stuff because it's not direct it's a
multi-step process with different
possibilities but it's important to know
where the single and double escape come
from where the five 11s come from which
is outside the detector yeah had a
question ionization cascade exactly yeah
so like if a 511 ke V photon enters the
detector the detector does not know
until an electron interaction happens so
most of the photons that entered this
detector leave the detector that's why
if he actually look at the banana stuff
which I'll pull up right now at the
efficiency
check out those values their
efficiencies in the realm of 10 to the
minus 4 or 10 to the minus 3 which is to
say that out of every thousand or 10,000
photons that enter the detector one of
them undergoes an electron interaction
and the other 9999 just goes screaming
on through and the detector does not
know where that they're they're the way
that Mike Ames got these efficiencies is
by putting a source of known activity in
calculating how many gammas that
detector should have picked up and
dividing and taking that divided by the
number that it actually picked up and so
that way you know how many gammas really
went in and how many gammas it saw and
that's how you get the detector
efficiency and you will have to account
for this when you do this on the
homework problem so the only quantities
you're gonna need is how many gamers did
it get what's the efficiency and then
back that out so you'll have to
calculate the activity of the bananas
and then figure out how much a banana
weighs and then you should know be able
to calculate the radioactivity of one
banana in Curie's or beccarose or micro
carries it's all it's all good it's a
good question so it's three of so I want
to let you guys go but I'll see you
again tomorrow when we'll review a
little bit of this stuff
and we'll get into more of the math of
the cross sections and why Compton
scattering and pair production take up
the energies that they do
you